something is coming something hungry for
blood
what is it the data for deep [ __ ] we
have to fall later see you tomorrow good
night ladies
kiss throughout night for me
well is is missing I don't know where he
is ninety-nine out of a hundred times
kid goes missing the kid is with a
parent or relative what about the other
time what you said ninety nine out of a
hundred what about the other time the
one the one guys I really think we
should turn back yes your back that's
not will you're in trouble aren't you
you've sealed off this area this word
came from yes and the girl she can't
have gone far
fine three you really think it was a
coincidence that we found her the same
place where we'll disappeared
something is going on here
what she knows about will is there any
way that you could reach him yes
that
worth is full time I've been looking for
well I've been chasing after something
else
I'm kid goes missing the kid is with a
parent or relative what about the other
time what you said 99 out of 100 what
about the other time the one